[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today I'm going to be talking
about the newest chapter chapter 308 of
the seven deadly sins manga and how the
series is going to end including what's
gonna happen to Melly Otis make sure to
LIKE and subscribe for more seven deadly
sins videos and also follow us on
Instagram at anime out drawer for daily
seven deadly sins posts and
conversations there obviously will be
manga spoilers in this video and without
further ado let's jump into it in the
new chapter we get confirmation about
the new season of the seven deadly sins
wrath of the Gods which definitely will
be airing in the fall of 2019 the first
24 episode season covered about 100
chapters from the manga and the second
24 episode season covered up to chapter
196 so roughly we're doing about 100
manga chapters per season slightly less
now we already got 308 chapters and the
manga is still not over so potentially
they could squeeze all the rest of the
manga into a last 24 episode season but
I think we should get even more episodes
not only with over 110 animated chapters
be jam packin more manga chapters into a
season than they've been doing thus far
we also have so many crazy events and
battles happening later on in the manga
including the memories of the holy war
assault mode Mele Otis versus the one
mode esken or Cusack and Chandler
purgatory king of rock versus a confused
Archangel the demon king and it's still
not over I'd say that they could easily
do two more seasons or at least another
24 episode season followed by a shorter
twelve episode season to finish off the
series if they don't split it up this is
definitely gonna be one of the most
fast-paced action-packed seasons in
anime history to be honest most of my
favorite parts have yet to be animated
so I'm definitely feeling the hype drop
a hashtag new season hype in the
comments if you're also psyched and let
me know what parts you can't wait to see
animated chapter 308 starts with some
natural disasters taking place in the
north we have violent weather that's
panicking the animals in the South the
land has split open there's a seething
anger and
that is welling up from deep within the
chasm we are told it's as if all across
Britannia the land is reacting to
something this picture that knockabout
paints is one that directly contrasts
the happiness and easygoing this of the
last chapter where we saw everyone
having fun and joking around in the bar
that was the type of scene you'd expect
to be the very last scene of a series
our friends have been through a lot
met a lot of friends along the way after
dangerous tests and tribulations they've
accomplished their goals and now
everyone gets together to celebrate and
they all live happily ever after
however knockabout gives us that perfect
ending just to subvert it in the last
chapter at the end bond interrupts the
perfect idyllic atmosphere by pointing
out that the captain will be leaving
them this was hinted at as far back as
chapter 285 when Mele Otis first awoke
to his power he mentioned that he was
afraid to use it because when he got
back to the other side he wouldn't be
able to stay there but he decides that
he needs to use it to defeat the demon
king anyways then many chapters later
the demon king seems to refer to the
same power of Mele Otis's as his inner
demon lord power he says now that a Mele
Otis has awakened to this power he can't
stay in this mortal plane for more than
a day so we saw this coming Mele Otis
would have to leave earth or the human
world I assumed that this was because
his power was just too much for the
human plane to handle and that was
confirmed in the newest chapter bon
tells us while he's in bed with Elaine
no one tell King that the power Mele
Otis attained was too massive in order
to maintain the balance in this world
the world is trying to reject him so it
would seem that all of the natural
disasters from earlier are the result of
the power balance Mele Otis is causing
he'll need to either leave soon or the
world might very well destroy itself
now that is Opie my friends he doesn't
even need the clash fist with anyone
like goku and beerus did in the Dragon
Ball super movie however if we look at
the demon King's words closely he says
that he won't be able to stay in this
mortal plane so chances are he can stay
in other mortal planes like the demon
realm /
Kotori and other non-human worlds in
fact this eventual separation might have
been foreshadowed as early as the first
episode during the intro we are told
that this story takes place during an
era before the human and non-human
worlds were forever divided so we knew
from the beginning that that division
would eventually happen perhaps it is
just going to happen sooner than we
expected even if the division doesn't
happen on a grand scale would it be that
bad if malleolus had to leave to another
plane or world this whole chapter
everyone gets the sense that Mellie Otis
will be leaving but everyone is
tiptoeing around the subject the an
finally breaks down and says the captain
wouldn't leave us would he and then we
figure out that Elizabeth already knows
that Mellie Otis is going to disappear
from this world Elizabeth has totally
accepted the fact and she looks
completely cool with it she smiles and
says he's gonna disappear from this
world but it's okay even if Mellie Otis
was keeping a secret from her and he
seems to feel concerned about it at
different points elizabeth has been
prepared this can suggest multiple
things it could suggest that Elizabeth
has accepted that she won't get to be
with Mellie Otis anymore maybe she's
just grateful for all the time that they
have spent together and realizes that
Mellie Otis must go but she could have
another plan in her mind she might plan
to accompany Mellie Otis to another
non-human plane where they could spend
the rest of their lives together yes it
would be awesome if all the sins could
spend the rest of their lives on earth
but if at least everyone gets to be with
their lover and at least visit the
others every so often that wouldn't be
so bad especially since they have been
preparing us for this division since the
first episode and more specifically
since chapter 285 for these reasons it
is likely that Mellie Otis will leave
this plane since the Hmong has been
preparing us for that for so long
however it is a possibility at least
that they will find a way for Mellie
Otis to stay for the time being
even if Elizabeth seems prepared for
Mellie Otis to leave this world the
series has made it clear to us before
that is possible to seal away a part of
your power Merlyn had sealed away a part
of Mellie Otis's power in the past in a
goddess amber obviously his current
power is incomparable to the amount
he had sealed the way back then but
perhaps there are other ways to seal
away power that would be even more
effective another possibility is that
Mellie Otis could give away the demon
king power there is a precedent for this
- Eska noir was able to give sunshine to
mild so it may be possible that Mellie
Otis could give away his power that's
keeping him from staying in this world
it was actually my brother and the other
half of anime uproar ana Mack who
suggested to me that Mellie Otis might
give the demon king power to sell dress
obviously we have no idea where zelgius
is right now we don't even know if he's
alive or dead but in my opinion he has
to be alive this is because we haven't
seen his reunion with gelda yet or
meliodas grieve for him or Milly Otis
help gelda before he has to leave in the
past meliodas showed guilt over not
being a good brother to zelgius it was
one of the things that continually
bothered him he then decided that he
will help his brother bring his lover
back and do his best to right the wrongs
of the past for these reasons it
wouldn't make sense for Mellie Otis to
just continue acting happy and hanging
out with his friends if his brother died
he has evolved as a brother and his
concern for his low brother is clear he
would have checked on his brother after
the battle got his best to help him and
if he couldn't save him we would have
seen him mourning his death since we
didn't it is likely that he survived and
he's doing his own thing maybe rescuing
gelda and will catch up with his
adventures with what exactly has been up
to soon enough it has also been hinted
at that zelgius could be the demon king
we are told that only Mellie Otis and
zelgius could hope to successfully
absorb the demon King's Commandments
it's too much dark power to handle for
anyone else except the actual sons of
the demon king this is one of the
reasons why my al went so crazy the more
Commandments he absorbed in additions
I'll just always hope to be the demon
king we learned in chapter 304 that
zelgius secretly plans to become the
demon king and create a world where
everyone could live in peace this was
his dream even when he had to choose
between gelda and the demon clan he
couldn't turn his back on the clan like
Mellie Otis did for Elizabeth Mellie
Otis as long
as we knew him never really wanted to be
the demon king he wanted to save
Elizabeth from the curse that was his
goal his primary focus has always been
Elizabeth and he would gladly give up
the demon king power for her to be with
her and make her happy
thus it would make more sense for the
brother who always wanted to be the
demon king who never betrayed the demon
clan and whose vampire girlfriend would
have an easier time living in the demon
realm to become the demon king while
Mele Otis stayed on earth with the love
of his life and his friends I personally
would like to see this zelgius becomes
the demon king ending happen because it
would mean that both zelgius and
meliodas could live out their dreams
zelgius can work towards bringing peace
as the demon king and millie ODIs can
spend his days as the owner of the bar
hanging out with the love of his life
and his best friends as he always wanted
to do so those are some of the possible
ways the seven deadly sins could end
obviously there still are so many
unanswered questions
what's the supreme deity plotting the
demon king could read the minds of
people who had part of this power so
does that mean that the goddess is aware
of what miele knows since he has a part
of her power in the form of the great
sunshine perhaps you can even read
Elizabeth's thoughts since Elizabeth
received some power in the past from her
mother to supreme deity are we really
never gonna see King Arthur again did
knockabout really kill off King Arthur
in a series based on Arthurian legend
after hyping him up Merlin and cath saw
him as a young man of unfathomable
talent and character and still unknown
magic hidden within it Merlin laments
that she wasn't able to draw out his
dormant potential and asks if his soul
is still in his body does it make sense
to kill off King Arthur after hyping up
all of his untapped potential and
Excalibur
I don't think so we've seen multiple
characters escape death in this show
through different means so I expect to
hear more about King Arthur before the
series is over
Meli ODIs also mentioned that the demon
Kings body is still in purgatory when he
was fighting against it so I'm also
curious what could have possibly
happened to that body did they kill his
soul and it's an empty shell or a part
of
is still there in purgatory but he just
can't hope to beat Mellie Otis anymore
what is Hawkes mama the mother of chaos
up - well that plot point ever be
addressed again I really want to see
mile into one mode because I think that
would just be crazy and I'm wondering if
he will eventually inherit the supreme
deities position because I think just as
there needs to be a strong acting ruler
of the demon realm there should be a
strong acting ruler of the celestial
realm and what is the connection between
Mellie Otis mal there's so much
crossover in parallels drawn between the
two including the fact that Mellie Otis
is aged poster and demon king self looks
strikingly similar to Myles
this has yet to be addressed and I'd
like to know more about their possible
connection lastly in the beginning of
this chapter we are told that seething
anger and rage Wells up from deep within
the chasm located in the south although
I get that Mellie Otis's power would be
causing natural disasters I still find
it curious that the word seething anger
and rage were used is that a hint that
something is about to be released from
there perhaps another enemy otherwise I
don't see why Mellie Otis's power would
be associated with things like anger and
rage at this point you know who would
have a reason to be filled with anger
and rage about the demons and other
races getting along the supreme deity
just saying like always we'll have to
wait and see what's going on but those
are some of the main things I'd like to
see cleared up before the series wraps
up things for good although in truth I
don't want it to end at all but when the
main character becomes as strong as
Mellie Otis is right now this series
probably can't go on for much longer
because enemies won't really stand a
chance anyways let me know if there are
any unsolved mysteries that you're still
wondering about in the comments and that
is it for today's video thank you so
much for watching if you enjoyed this
video definitely smash that like button
to let me know if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so you get notified when future seven
deadly sins videos come out follow us on
Instagram - for daily seven deadly sins
updates and greatness let me know what
seven deadly sins videos you would like
to see in the future as well a big thank
you goes out to our awesome patrons
especially to our Protea patrons keelon
and the one and all
Gilgamesh and are the one tier patrons
the ones who stand atop all clans James
a lo'laan attempt infused silver
Mattie Mac 239 and a 17 ffvp thanks so
much for your ongoing support if you get
value from the stuff we do consider
supporting us for as little as a dollar
a month over on our patreon if you
become a patron your name will appear in
future videos along with these amazing
people right here and you'll get access
to our patron only discord thank you so
much for watching and until next time
see you space cowboys
[Music]
you